e da un po che non registra un video non
so ragazzi se conoscete che ne sanno i
2000 non sto parlando della canzone di
capri ponte che conoscete tutti
per chi non lo sapesse ragazzi che ne
sanno i 2000 e una pagina di facebook in
tv porta i ricordi dell'infanzia e ti fa
risvegliare a schiaffi in faccia da
quella che è il presente ne parla
proprio adesso perché in questo periodo
di fermo mi è capitato di girovagare su
facebook e di vedere che un mio amico
aveva colpito delle cose appunto che
hanno risvegliato il bambino game e
quindi volevo commentarle davanti a voi
oggi perché sono veramente preso bene
dal fatto che io posso parlarvi un po
del mio passato del nostro passato se
siete sotto i 2000 se siete sopra i
duemila non capito un cazzo si scherza
basta basta mettere di strike e ai video
basta ma chi sarà mai questo invito vi
risponde al signor fare questo individuo
questo pseudo justin bieber dei del 2010
si chiama cornejo e jesse mccartney che
fa era un cantante che andava un sacco
di moda i miei tempi e ha fatto due
canzoni famose poi non se n'è mai pagato
nessuno però non capisco il motivo in
realtà perché era un bel ragazzo andrà
bene però fatto successo justin bieber
fa ridere perché jesse mccartney e oltre
ad aver fatto parte della nostra
infanzia ha fatto anche un film che
stiamo a chernobyl diaries che non
c'entra un cazzo con tutto quello che
abbiamo ben 100.000 ieri son film dove
gruppo di ragazzi vanno a chernobyl e
poi scoprono che sono rimasti alle
persone nel vicino al reattore tutte
mutate che tentano di ucciderli
andiamo avanti ragazzi finalmente di
un'immagine che sono io e il mio cugino
più grande e io io sono rimasto così il
mio cugino quindi conoscesse questi due
ragazzoni anzi il ragazzino e ne sono
rey mysterio e battista che voi
conoscete al giorno logicom and druks
criticamente non guardo non ho mai visto
avendo sandra proprio lui che ha fatto
anche avengers insomma fatto ma io che
sono un essere umano normale lo conosco
per che faceva landauer grip ed era
anche il campione del mondo della
videobb quindi era era era il mio
preferito è incredibile nota mette bizet
mi hanno fatto vedere un video che sono
andati da batista in mezzo al pubblico e
gli hanno chiesto di farli la batista
bomb e l'artista gli ha detto no e
metteteci sono rimasti male e che cosa
che eravate che mi rispondesse davanti a
tutti ma si limita la faccia ti spacco
per terra fuori e poi io vado in carcere
la mia carriera è finita no ovviamente
un anno fa quando si desidera rey
mysterio che non si sa come diavolo
fosse possibile ma faceva 26.000
acrobazie per fare la fiction nine che
era la sua mostra finale nella libreria
da piccolo g giochiamo veramente un
sacco ci giocavo perché c'è anche la
playstation
wow ma passiamo ragazzi ora uno dei più
grandi misteri della nostra infanzia che
ancora oggi secondo me non si è spiegato
allora facciamo vedere i video si
diranno photoshop allora praticamente
cosa succede succede che queste scatole
di biscotti ok che hanno l'apparenza
l'immagine di biscotti sopra aveva un
problema il problema grosso quando tu
andavi dalla nonna ma io anche a casa
mia cioè ero era così anche a casa mia
ovviamente c'era nel cassetto tu ti lavi
cassetto dentro c'era questa scatola di
biscotti con la figurativi scattato in
una fame da lupi incredibile andavi li
aprivi la scatola di biscotti e dentro e
non so per quale minori dilatare lo
sapete tutti c'erano praticamente
dell'etna ago e filo no non quelle dei
limi crossing questo questa roba c'era
questa roba ma non ho capito per quale
molti giro so perché quella scatola
utilizzata solo
per materiale tessile nessuno nessuno
qua c'è titoli video ti diranno
conosciamo nessuno dentro ci ha mai
trovato i biscotti sempre roba da cucire
ad esempio io ho preso quella di mia
nonna che l'ho tenuta insomma perché è
un cimelio durava una vita perché
ovviamente mica scadono gli a due film e
dentro ci sono sempre roba non ho
staccato dagli altri a questa parte
allora ragazzi quali ho un senso questo
e sofisticata questa è veramente
sofisticato se ve la ricordate
possiamo limonare c'erano queste scatole
erano vere e proprie a forma di
sigaretta però all'interno di questa
carta che vedete targata simpson
c'erano delle gomme da masticare ma
lunga era è una cosa era una sigaretta
fatta con la gomma da masticare cultura
scartavetra mangiato il problema perché
c'è la stampa sta dentro cemento la
mastica architetti mall big babol solo
che era una stecca così e quindi a fune
di masticarla ti rimaneva in bocca ma
pazzo enorme che questi tentolini dalla
bocca e lo rielabora vi potevi fare le
fondamenta beh quelli che oggi sono i
grattacieli di new york ragazzi abbiamo
parlato già di tante cose ma c'era una
particolarità andavamo piccoli
avete presente le le kinder brioss
insomma le belle brioche che mangi per
me è ok quando eravamo piccoli noi le
sorprese che trovi dentro queste brioche
ci ascoltavano la giornata mi ricordo
che c'erano alcune di si incastrano tra
di loro creando totem bellissimo andare
cupra e le brioche
all'interno c'erano stint i regalini
stand sorpresine no erano collezionabili
più delle volte quindi dovevi comprare
vari patti brioche fino ad avere la
dispensa della kinder in casa per poter
avere tutte le sorprese aver fibra
protezione ce n'era una in particolare
che mi è entrata proprio nel cuore che
era questa perché questi sono
collezionabili che trovi appunto dentro
le dentro invece da kinder ed erano
volte se ricordate bene sono dei bidoni
dell'immondizia
qualcuno nella sede della kinder che si
è seduta ha detto signori per fare i
collezionabili giusti che piace nei
bambini
cos'è che mettiamo i bidoni
dell'immondizia e tutti gli altri
bravo e che ci crediate o no ragazzi ha
funzionato funzionato il sacco perché mi
piace un sacco ha tutti altri bambini
piacevano i bidoni dell'immondizia gli
piace non lo so questa che state vedendo
e un narrare immagini di aver perso
storico di un telefono utilizzato dagli
egizi questo qua e loki a 5300 ex plus
minus attenzione la terminologia e
importa in questo affare facevano basta
non siamo niente io lo farei vedere
perché c'è l'opera non c'e loquace lo a
torino nella mercato dove sono cresciuto
niente un telefono che fa una cosa
strana gente non è un telefono un
compatto però poi slitta e diventa
comunque ci mettevi lo sfondo della
tectonic ed eri il numero uno della
classe di tanto in tanto mi guardo
attorno
e vedo la gente i bambini insomma di
oggi che giocano con l'ipad e fanno dei
giochini supini che magari spiegano dall
app store fatti apposta per insomma
intrattenerli un 10 minuti giochi che
magari devono darci un attimino di tempo
per ragionare su quello che stai facendo
e poi riuscire a farlo e passare al
livello successivo
finiscono in breve i bambini di oggi si
irrita un sacco lo vedo perché in giro
sono i bambini con live ad maledizione o
guardalinee controtempo giocano a
giochini stupidity i cori i bambini di
un tempo ovvero noi abbiamo fatto la
scuola per diventare marin da bambini
non avevamo la ipad avevamo questa fare
perché questo affare paprika mente i
veri credenti hanno la bibbia va bene
quelli che invece credono nel diavolo
pregano sta roba vedete questi questi
cerchietti che si infilano sono infilati
in delle stanghette ok praticamente c'è
questo affare erano cose di plastica in
nottata 4 the quest e tutti questi
anellini che dovete infilati quando non
erano infilati qua erano tutti in basso
e tu schiacciati questo pulsantone e
partiva un oggetto d'aria che faceva
volare tutti gli anellini questo gioco
consisteva nel efficace di tipo dentro
nessuno ci è mai riuscito nessuno
io vi do io ve lo giuro ve lo giuro su
quanto di caro al mondo che non è
possibile se vuoi service e voi lo avete
avuto in passato sapete il piccolo sto
parlando chi non l'ha avuto credimi te
lo giuro su quello che vuoi non l'ho poi
non si può fare non sta roba da limpe
infatti sta roba non esiste cioè che
dovrebbe essere il legale cioè la fim
calcio di oggi non lo so ragazzi sono
anche ragazzi
concludiamo dicendo che la nostra
infanzia è stata difficile difficile
alle volte perché adorare dei bidoni
dell'immondizia giocare a scappare
facciale sfondi da
toni che è stato molto complicato ma
eravamo felici così se ne volete un
altro fatemelo sapere nei commenti
magari mi scrivete una cosa che vi
ricordate la vostra infanzia e famosa
tipo queste io vado a commentarle magari
si faccia un altro video del genere si
vedono di commenti ragazzi però che vi
sia piaciuto
spero che la vostra infanzia vi sia
piaciuta perchè la mia è stata
incredibile e noi ci dividiamo come
sempre anno prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]